Fixed.
Mel Gibson's dad was 92 and he was in a wheelchair and now he's a hundred and
he's walking around what the issue was.
Stem cells situation and and Americans,
I don't hear too much the last time.
I'm not probably as knowledge as you are but wasn't,
I'm Christopher Reeve trying to um,
promote stem more stem cell research.
I'm sure he was.
Yeah.
He had that spinal cord injury from the Horse for horse accident.
He was doing those horse jumps.
Yeah,
South Park thing.
Remember,
I don't remember by levels eating dead babies to like get the stem cells.
They 12 [inaudible] Alvin his we'll take a bad turn.
Yeah,
they're going to have a soda about rape on South Park.
They don't give a fuck.
They are the best.
It gives shelled out there.
There are also pushing the boundaries.
They're the ones out there that are promoting like ridiculous,
preposterous comedy that's completely offensive but brilliant.
That's one of the things that when we were doing a Chappelle show,
the,
one of the things I appreciate more than anything about this show was how it put
people are racist.
You backgrounds together to do the thing that we all should have in common and
that's the laugh and also to not push the button but touch on retro stuff
without having angry undertone and that's what's so fucked up about American
now.
Whenever you talk about race,
it feels like one side,
somebody has to be tense.
You know what I'm saying is never like a comfortable saves.
Never like,
and I know things are intense but we have to be able to laugh first.
Once you get people to laugh,
you can talk about whatever you want and then even if a person is not in
agreement or have the same thoughts at the end of the day you should be at a
respect that person.
And I think those same people should be able to share a laugh.
Yeah and there was a a fun,
silly non aggressive quality to the way you guys put together sketches that got
the point across in everybody laughed.
Everybody laughed at,
I joke to this to this day when I travel and I do my audiences.
It's interesting because of course you would think I'm going to draw a certain
audience because I'm black,
which I,
you know,
which I am and I do,
but it's weird.
I could go to places and it's straight up like Dave,
column d,
The muddy boot motherfuckers,
you know what I'm saying?
Like the money boot motherfuckers,
the money boost to jail,
they got John Deere.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
They know all that elk shit you talking about,
you know,
do John Deere is know all this shit.
They probably call her right now and say,
no Joe,
I think you get that wrong.
You got to cut the heart from,
you know,
you've got to go left or right.
You know what I'm saying?
And I've noticed I have those people and that I have heard people,
but it just,
just when you can look out,
and this is what I showed it,
when you can look at an audience and you say you have all of America there,
it was the best sketch comedy show in the history of television,
I think.
I think in living color is very,
very,
very overlooked.
People forget how God damn raking and groundbreaking.
It was bright in both of them.
Like it's wherever I go.
People always,
they always bring it up as a big point in my career,
but I was like as a,
I don't know if we have it every 10 years or 15 years,
it comes a time where,
uh,
the audience wants something different.
Sex Shit,
water down.
Same way when in limit colors saying we would def comedy jam came out,
you know,
you,
you didn't see a lot of uh,
a black standards on TV,
but they had this underground circuit.
It was bubbling,
that was bubbling and it was,
it was the right time when he pulled out the right time in living color comes
around,
it's the right time.
The Dave Chappelle show comes around.
It's the right time to Richard partial.
Even though that only lasted three or four episode,
it was the right time and it caught on it the right time.
Yeah.
Um,
in terms of like groundbreaking sketch comedy shows though,
like that,
that,
that k k k bit where he had the blind tell you something.
Do you understand in the history of sketch,
nobody has premiered a sketch show and it came off so hardcore the first night
it's hot as hell.
She's hard as it comes.
When they ended that shit when we asked why,
why after all these years would you so,
so he was like,
because she's a nigger lover.
I was like,
that was one of them.
That was one of the joints.
I'm like,
wake up everybody no more sleeping in bed.
No.
From that moment that does show was going to be on the next level of shots.
Well was he was free.
It was,
it was so many when we did,
funny thing,
a lot of things I used to do,
I was a warmup comedian for a Chappelle show.
So whenever you saw Chappelle show episode,
if you notice that whenever I came on screen and I'm not being cocky,
people would go nuts.
They'd be like,
Oh shit.
And the reason was because I was a guy that wanted the ordinance before Dave
came out.
Ah.
So I knew if I go gut the room out at the beginning,
people don't eat.
People don't even,
they didn't,
nobody knew I was there anything.
If I ripped that at the beginning and then when they see me on the screen it's
going to be like,
it's going to be big horse and [inaudible] that show man.
It was just like,
it was just like a lot of things happen to show people like Rick James Sketch
the day we played that during the wrap arounds.
Man,
that should hit so hard.
I was like,
this shit is fucking crazy.
Crazy funny thing people don't know is that comedy central did not like that
sketch
comedy central.
Here's the,
this got,
it's funny.
Comedy Central,
they're like sketch and comedy central.
Didn't think Charlie Murphy was funny in it
and I watched,
we ran as shit sick just to let you know the direction people think I wasn't
shit six times and every time man,
every time you heard Dave say,
I'm Rick James Bitch,
it was gut son.
It was gut side.
Yo,
what did the father figures say to the faced?
Where's,
where's Lantz?
You had a sketch was getting kids to spend it in school,
right?
People was born school day teachers went the five fingers.
I say Rick James Bitch.
All right Tom,
you suspended for a week.
You add Dave Chappelle,
go to the fucking time out room is one of the most iconic sketches of all time.
How wrong was comedy central?
I mean not just a little wrong lot along the way.
Wrong all the way wrong.
Like almost like suicidal.
It was like hmm.
But then it goes to show him like it goes to show,
you know how you have a vision was something you see it.
Everybody may not see it.
Well that's the problem with working with executives to right.
It's like their vision is different than your vision.
They would like to ship shape you in a certain way and you know,
and I know Dave ran into problems with them wanting him to change language so
they could get more sponsors.
Yeah.
I think,
I think that that wasn't an issue.
And to be quite honest,
I don't know exactly what happened.
Everything is speculation.
He never talked to him about,
never talked to him about it because the reason why I never talked to him about
it because I didn't need to talk to them about it.
You know what I'm saying?
Um,
that show was great for me.
It was a great Frey platform for me.
And then out it was more important,
my friendship and how he felt away from that was more important then.
So why'd you leave?
Where'd you go?
First Time I saw him or like as long as you,
okay.
Cause this is gonna be scary for anybody.
One of your closest friends,
somebody you work with all of a sudden just goes to another country.
You don't hear from him,
you know?
But when I first saw him after that,
like I was excited and I would just like,
you know,
with whatever it was,
we had a moment we may history and people go on,
people go on to do other things and just keep it moving.
Well,
that show was really,
people always say Daniel,
if it wasn't for the Chapelle show,
this and that.
[inaudible]
gave me a platform for people to see what I've been doing for years.
And you know,
you see talents in the club now you see a muffin is good shit,
good shit.
But when they get the right platform for the world scene,
you know what I'm saying?
And that's kind of separate.
Um,
you see one person go from one level to the next level who has the right
platform to showcase their talent and that should show did that for me.
And with that said,
I gave that show everything every time I had a second on camera.
Every time.
Like if you look at two and a half years on this show,
if you had an editor breakdown how many times I spoke,
it would probably be a total of four minutes.
I'll get a word here,
I get a phrase here,
but I told myself whenever they turn that motherfucking camera,
I'm going for it.
Like,
even if I'm not talking,
I'm going to make my body so expressive that your eyeball draws too with no,
I remember Neal told me one time,
he said,
because I always,
I always get a mic cause I'll come up with a line or something to throw in.
And we were doing a Rick James Sketch and I didn't have a mic.
I was like,
Yo,
uh,
sound.
And Neil said you're not going to get a mic bro.
I said,
am I my I was like,
I might say something like,
you're not going to say anything.
I was like fuck.
So I told myself,
well he smacks this motherfucker cause if you look at their same,
when he smacks me,
I say what the f?
I was like,
um,
like uh,
uh,
watch the square park mime.
I pushed that.
I said what thought fuck I made my face.
He didn't give me a mic,
but I said what the fuck with my face.
And I always as people always as a matter of showing as young actors and stuff
like that,
can you talk to me?
What do you need to,
I was like with anything,
the best thing to do is figure out a way to get on a set.
You get on a set,
you,
you do background,
you learn,
you get opportunities.
You got to be around it.
You've got to get a skill set,
but when it's time to show up,
you gotta show up.
You have to show up.
Motherfuckers talk a lot of shit.
I want to do this out there.
And then when they say action of them saying ready to show up.